the movie is set in a dystopian 2034
where south korea has been ravaged by a
deadly flu it is said that this virus is
10 times deadlier than kovid 19
resulting in hundreds and thousands of
deaths the condition is so severe that
even birds are shot by the military so
that they don't transmit the disease to
other countries as a result of this flu
people die on the streets cars crash
into each other and in short the city
has gone into chaos when there is no
place left to bury the dead bodies the
government piles them up like trash in a
large stadium and burns them all at once
this is the peak of the flu but to know
how it began let's go back to a few
weeks earlier it all started in hong
kong where a shipping container full of
illegal immigrants is being readied for
transport to bandang south korea as the
manager inspects the people inside
someone suddenly starts coughing
vigorously despite this he gives the all
clear and the container is dispatched on
its journey elsewhere in bandang a woman
named kim in hey is involved in an
accident and now her car has fallen into
a construction hole in no time the
rescue squad arrives but the car has
been stuck in such a spot that only one
person can go inside at a time a guy
named kanjiku takes the initiative and
slowly makes his way down to kim the
situation is so precarious that if they
make too much movement the car will
plunge further down despite this jiku
uses his experience and eventually
rescues kim after the successful rescue
operation jiku approaches kim and tries
to initiate a conversation but the
latter simply ignores him and leaves in
the ambulance cold-blooded that night
kim calls jiku and asks to meet at the
same spot where the accident took place
jiku is excited believing that kim has
called him to appreciate his efforts
however on reaching he becomes dejected
to find out that she has simply called
him to retrieve her bag from the hole he
initially refuses claiming that it is
against their protocol but after kim
leaves he enters the hole and retrieves
the bag with the help of one of his
colleagues after this he searches
through the bag and finds an identity
card which shows that kim is a doctor
just then the phone inside starts
ringing and jiku answers it hesitantly
kim's daughter me roo is on the other
side and after a small chat jiku agrees
to meet her after school meanwhile two
brothers byung ki and bieng approach the
container with the illegal immigrants
when they open it they are taken aback
to find everyone dead all except for one
there is also a very powerful stench
inside the container confused about what
to do the brothers take videos of the
scene and put the lone survivor inside
their truck after a while they stop at a
grocery store and bianchi heads inside
to get some supplies sensing the
opportunity the survivor makes a run for
it when bianchi returns from the store
he notices that the man has escaped and
that his brother is coughing profusely
he tries chasing the survivor but
ultimately gives up and instead takes
his brother to a clinic there the doctor
gives bieng woo some normal
prescriptions and asks him to rest but
biengmu cannot stop coughing he spreads
his droplets to all the people in his
vicinity elsewhere jiku visits meru
outside her school and tries to start a
conversation but just like her mother
meeru refuses to interact she simply
takes her mother's bag and jiku's
business card before leaving as jiku is
headed home he notices some people
coughing vigorously on the bus nearby
following this we are shown a montage of
how the virus is slowly taking over the
city of bandang later when kim reaches
home she gets ecstatic to find that her
bag has been returned she hugs her
daughter with joy and also thanks jiku
for his help just as the mother-daughter
duo is bonding kim gets a call from her
hospital informing her that there has
been a sudden emergency left with no
other options she leaves meeru in the
care of her grandmother when kim arrives
at the hospital she notices that
everyone is scared she immediately heads
into the emergency room where byeong-woo
the patient is in a critical state he
has coughed up a lot of blood and has
red rashes on his body kim deduces that
it is avian flu and tells her seniors
about it but they are not convinced soon
after the doctors get a hold of
byeongwu's phone and find the footage of
the container filled with dead bodies
they are sure that the virus originated
from there and approached the patient's
brother bianchi to ask about it but he
remains silent suddenly an emergency
alarm starts blaring and this makes
bianchi anxious despite the doctor's
warning he wrestles everyone and rushes
into the emergency room only to find
that his brother has passed away
devastated he breaks down and hugs his
brother causing his hands to get stained
with blood bianchi then touches several
of the doctors with his hands but after
a long struggle he is finally subdued in
the next scene meeru gets bored and
ventures out of her house alone she is
almost hit by a vehicle but monsai the
survivor from the container saves her
meru notices that he is hungry and
provides him with some food as they talk
mansai warns the little girl to stay
away from him since he is sick but meru
continues talking to him a while later
monsae starts coughing prompting mirou
to get some aid she calls jiku for help
but by the time he arrives
mansai is already gone by this time
thousands of people in the city have
become infected by the virus resulting
in the hospitals becoming overcrowded
with patients on the other hand kim
along with a team of the kcdc the korea
centers for disease control and
prevention locate the container and
incinerate all the dead bodies inside
kcdc is playing their hit song tnt
however a large swarm of rats that had
been feeding on the corpses manages to
escape into the city meanwhile a medical
team consisting of top doctors from
around the country hold an emergency
meeting after a heated conversation the
team concludes that the deadly virus is
a modified version of the h5n1 strain
which can kill its victims within 36
hours they also instruct the higher
officials to quarantine the city or else
it may spread to the whole country and
even the world elsewhere jiku has taken
mirou to a supermarket there they have
lunch and start bonding while sharing
some of their secrets with each other
after a while as they prepare to leave
chaos begins to unfold people start
coughing up blood and falling
unconscious some of them even die on the
spot jiku notices a woman about to fall
from the escalator and saves her but in
the process he loses sight of meru back
at the emergency meeting the doctors and
politicians get into an argument as some
of them deem the quarantine unnecessary
probably the politicians during this
time a series of accidents occur outside
resulting in mass casualties now the
virus is spreading at such a rapid rate
that the hospitals and communication
systems have become overwhelmed and the
quarantine is forcefully initiated
fearing for their lives the politicians
and doctors decide to fly to seoul and
continue their research there as the
researchers plan to evacuate the city dr
kim informs her colleagues that she will
join them later after she finds her
daughter she calls me roo but geek who
picks up and briefs her about the
situation in the supermarket wasting no
time she reaches the place but is
devastated to find that her daughter is
missing soon the situation gets out of
control when people start looting the
stores and fighting against each other
as a result the army is deployed and a
huge brawl ensues kim and jiku search
for the little girl amidst the chaos and
after a while they finally find her the
three then get out of the supermarket
just before the shutter is closed once
they are out of danger kim requests that
jiku leave the city along with them but
he refuses claiming that it is his duty
to help the people he then hands him his
car keys and sends them away after a
while he teams up with one of his
colleagues and releases the people
trapped inside the supermarket meanwhile
kim and her daughter reach the airport
and pass the security checks but just as
they are about to head towards the final
chopper to seoul meeru starts coughing
and as a result they are denied entry
that night the korean army along with
the us forces and the kcdc reinforce a
strict lockdown throughout the city all
the residents are relocated to a
quarantine camp at an emergency meeting
in seoul the politicians team up with
national and international physicians
and come to the conclusion that the
citizens will be tested and then
segregated as infected or uninfected one
of the physicians claims that mixing the
two sets of people will result in an
even bigger spread of the virus but the
others tell them to remain silent their
path is to release the ones who don't
show any symptoms while the infected
will be treated in a separate ward
meanwhile at the camp kim arrives with
her daughter and notices the dilapidated
state of the place people barely have
space to move let alone live some of
them are already coughing up blood while
others live in constant fear that they
will be infected next later while kim is
tying her daughter's hair she notices
red rashes on her neck despite this she
takes meru through the examination room
and into the quarantine camp the next
morning on the government's orders some
soldiers gather on rooftops and shoot at
the birds fearing that they will
transmit the virus to other places down
in the camp monsae is finally discovered
by the authorities after examining him
the doctors are taken aback to find out
that he has somehow overcome the virus
and developed an immunity they then call
kim to start working on an antibody as
she is the only doctor in the camp who
knows about the virus a few hours later
kim is successful in extracting the
antibody from him however when she
presents the idea of injecting the
antibodies directly into a patient her
seniors reject it that sounds like it
might work we can't do that later that
day while kim is trying to smuggle her
sick daughter out of the place a couple
of quarantine staff arrive trying to
locate meru using her tag number 2066
they mentioned that her results came out
positive so they are there to take her
kim is devastated that she is going to
be separated from her daughter but just
then jiku steps forward and introduces
himself as number 2066 with this the
guards take him away to the infected
zone later one of his friends spots him
and cleverly uses his own card to take
jiku out elsewhere kim enters the
special tent where monsae is being held
even though the higher authorities
instructed her against injecting the
antibodies directly she proceeds to use
it on meru who has now become extremely
sick kim starts a transfusion between
her daughter and monsae but a few
moments later the troops notice her and
barge inside they then put her to sleep
and take the infected meru away in the
next scene jiku witnesses guards
transporting a child's body into the
contaminated zone and assumes it is
meroose he pursues the men and discovers
meeru's headband along the way soon
after he reaches a place where thousands
of infected corpses are being wrapped up
in plastic some of them aren't even dead
yet as jiku continues searching for meru
he comes across a horrific sight a large
crane is grabbing a pile of dead bodies
and dumping them into a stadium which
has now become an incineration pit
fearing the worst he immediately heads
down to the pit and starts looking for
the girl as a large flame burns the
bodies jiku suddenly hears a ring tone
and realizes that it belongs to meru he
rushes to the location and finally
discovers the little girl wrapped in
plastic still alive meanwhile the
tension inside the quarantine camp has
reached a boiling point when an officer
fatally shoots an infected soldier the
crowd goes wild and erupts out of the
camp on their way out they notice jiku
saving meru from the burning pile of
corpses and deduced that the infected
are being incinerated alive because of
the public outburst the medical
personnel decide to leave the place and
continue their research on mansai
elsewhere they ask kim to accompany them
but she refuses claiming that she has to
find her daughter as they are heading
out bianchi notices monsae and fatally
stabs him as vengeance for the loss of
his brother at the same time kim
desperately searches for her daughter
around the camp but fails to find her as
a result she reluctantly leaves with the
medical staff back in seoul the
president witnesses the city of bandang
in a state of utter pandemonium he is
under constant pressure by a member of
the un schneider to eliminate the
infected so that they don't cross the
border despite this he orders the army
to stand down until an antibody is made
schneider and the vice president are not
happy with the decision but they decide
to wait for the antibody unfortunately
things take a turn for the worse when
monsai dies in the ambulance and with
him their hopes of developing an
antibody also dies when the vice
president learns of this he secretly
instructs the army to stop the outraged
civilians from entering the soul border
while several civilians are killed in
the shootout jiku somehow escapes the
place with meru who by this time has
started to feel better she is even able
to speak implying that the antibody
worked on her elsewhere kim rushes to
meet her daughter but she is stopped by
the armed soldiers she repeatedly
mentions that her daughter has the cure
so one of the soldiers takes her to
their base to communicate with the
president back on the street a man
overhears jiku saying that mirou has the
antibody so he goes after them when the
girl is alone he takes her to an
isolated room and tries to extract her
blood fortunately jiku arrives with his
friend and the three engage in a brutal
fight at last jikku manages to kill the
man but his best friend is severely
injured in the fight in the meantime kim
talks with the president and informs him
that her daughter has been totally cured
of the virus and may have the antibody
to it hearing this the president orders
his soldiers to hold their fire but
schneider isn't convinced and he tells
them to keep shooting after a while kim
reaches the border and when she sees
meru among the infected she runs towards
her unfortunately as she tries to take
her daughter over the containment line
she is shot as per the orders of
schneider but before the soldiers can do
further damage meru shields her mom and
repeatedly tells the men to not shoot
this warms the hearts of everyone
including the soldiers and they all
stand back even the infected people get
renewed motivation and they start
running towards the border on the other
hand when schneider sees the soldiers
refrain from shooting he goes full
wiener and calls in an airstrike this
enrages the president and he orders his
men to shoot the fighter planes if they
enter bandang as a result the two get
into a heated confrontation but at last
schneider backs down after the danger is
averted the president goes live and
announces to everyone that he will find
a cure and do whatever it takes to save
his people in the last scene miru is
sent to seoul to create a vaccine while
kim and jiku stay behind the movie ends
as a reporter announces that the vaccine
has become successful and the people of
bandang will be the first ones to
receive it after a bunch of rich white
americans of course subscribe for more
videos like this turn on notifications
and leave a like to help the channel out
thank you for watching